vous allez ça c'est encore ça c'est bon
c'est un peu embêtant mais il ya pire
il ya un garçon qui a demandé façon 59
58 ans degrés est une des femmes de
venir les jeux bandai chez lui parce que
oui un faux profil le plus grave c'est
que la meule fallait qu'elle est venue
les abords des routes vers surprise un
homme
anthony la roche propose à des femmes
qui l'a séduite en ligne de coucher avec
lui si parmi elles sophie la trentaine
[Musique]
elle finit par accepter la proposition
du bel anthony la roche
problème il n'existe pas
il s'agit en fait d'un homme de plus de
60 ans + papy que playboy mais sophie ne
le voit pas dans cet appartement
plongé dans le noir qui déshabille toi
mais le bandeau sur tes yeux et il est
venu me chercher il m'a emmené dans la
chambre et là il m'a attaché les mains
ou au lit et je réalise que j'ai été
violé parce que cet homme là je suis
jamais donné mon accord parce que c'est
pas cette personne n'a que j'allais voir
alors bon il a porté plainte pour viol à
la porte avec raison et après après et
c'est très très ce que tu arrivé il ya
eu viol et tout ça après il faut faire
aussi preuve d'un petit peu de bon sens
et on va pas chez quelqu'un les yeux
bandés consécration c'est ce que j c'est
un délit mais c'est bien ce que de bon
sens c'est que c'est un prédateur la
wiwi manager de la victime
ah oui déjà bien qu'elle soit rennais a
fait 13 km en voiture les seconds vérité
du site de rencontre quand même de faire
un peu attention pas possible non là où
ça a beaucoup changé sur tous les sites
de rencontre et n'a beaucoup c'est que
maintenant en revanche déjà les filtres
la photo c'est à dire que si vous mettez
une photo qui est trop dénudées trop
sexy fromages fins il ne l'a il ne la
valide pas ça n'était pas le cas avant
il ya aussi maintenant quand on signale
des gens quand on les bloque qui peuvent
être retirés donc il ya quand même une
vraie vérification en revanche ben oui
si la photo est normal vous mettez la
photo de quelqu'un de beau ils peuvent
pas vérifié dernière du bac bô n'y a pas
un père à l'âge de 115 ans et est ce que
vous vous mettez votre photo sur le site
de rencontre mais qui vous dit tout sur
un site
je te vois la honte et non le sien non
je n'ai pas ma faute aux abonnés quoi
bah on me dit quoi alors j'vais bas âge
mais quoi je m
je me sers à tort ce soit quelque chose
quelqu'un mais qui est parquée pas
dénudée mais mais mais qui est mais qui
est votre torse alors on discute un peu
et puis après j'ai des techniques pour
sonder voir si la personne était à peu
près normale
il ya eu aussi des sites de rencontres
des célébrités il fallait à je tombé sur
quelqu'un d'autre famille pendant
vraiment bon
charmant votre fils moi je trouve que le
site de rencontres pour moi il dénature
le rapport est que le rapport amoureux
il doit se faire les personnels font
connaissance et ça doit se faire petit à
petit et j'ai l'impression que le site
de rencontre et cassent un peu cette
magie assuré 21h tout le monde mais là
là on pas monsieur de rencontre
clairement oui le but on va pas se
mentir c'est à dire en contre et de 6,6
à massy bien sûr que si le magma on met
l'amour il peut arriver n'importe où ici
sur le plateau dans la rue au feu rouge
ou au café aux toilettes à bord tout est
un exemple j'ai un exemple jean-louis
qui pourrait peut-être vous ressemble et
c'est benzema cdd façon de draguer assez
comment dirais-je
merci beaucoup ce n'était que vous avez
marqué il y aurait il du bon direct et
ça c'est quand même c'est un peu gênant
à prague en ligne ne s'encombre pas
toujours des bonnes manières
charmante ça va ça va très bien merci
thème les grosses gouttes comme ça un
témoin rendez vous je passe m'occuper de
toi je te mets des faits c'est moi quand
on me parle comme ça ça attise la
curiosité j'ai tout de suite envie de
savoir qui se cache derrière un ton
aussi cache pas jusqu'à la sirène pas me
prendre la tête derrière cette
application c'est simplement une peluche
tout simplement dit
je n'ai pas dû être assez clair ce soir
là
tu t'es touché coquine et coquine on
était là
grosse cerise sur le gâteau cette photo
de son sexe en érection envoyés sur mon
téléphone
c'est évidemment pas moi la ccpo déjà
c'est un délit aussi vide reste à voir
si on sait que c'est un des lignes bien
sûr au maire là où mathieu à tort
également c'est que la journaliste dans
le reportage tente de joindre le site en
l'occurrence chez passion donne son nom
au green door et d'encre elle n'y arrive
pas c'est à dire que ils ne veulent pas
répondre à ces messages
ils ne veulent rien faire donc les sites
sont responsables moi je vais vous dire
à l'époque je faisais ça sur minitel
dans les airs c'était à li na li vous
connaissez aussi
[Applaudissements]